This is the Super Hard Quiz of Doom and our last question on finite state machines
and regular languages and regular expressions.
This requires quite a bit of abstract thinking so don't feel bad if this takes a number of tries.
These questions are always, sometimes, and never.
I've written out two claims, and what I want you to do is mark this box if the first claim is always true,
mark this box if they're sometimes when it's true and sometime when it's false,
and this box if it's never true. So here's the first claim.
Suppose I have any finite state machine A. You draw it out for me.
Can I then make a new finite state machine that accepts strings of the following form?
For any string that's in yours, I then get another string that's in yours
and I accept their concatenation when I glue them together.
This is a little hard to get a feeling for but let's imagine my finite state machine A accepted
ba ba ba, that sort of thing.
Then I want to make a new finite state machine that accepts
ba ba, ba ba, ba ba, doublings of the first finite state machine.
Down here, I have a very similar claim but with one bit change.
If I have a finite state machine B, can I make a new finite state machine that accepts strings
of this form--x concatenated with x where x was a string accepted by B?
So if you give me a finite statement machine that only recognizes hello,
can I make a new finite machine that recognizes hello, hello?
I don't know why you'd say that. Anyway, give this some thought. This may take some extra time.